well old and young
uh i hope she will have a great
introduction to time traveling
simulators using blockchains and their
applications because
that's what justin's about to tell us so
um but due to the format of the of the
of the
of the panel so if anyone uh who watched
the video from the audience uh has a
question uh you can
either
ask questions of the q a or if you can
immute yourself you can just ask justin
otherwise he would just give his small
presentation so if anyone has a question
now you can type in the chat or in the q
a
and i'll
or just ask if you're going to unmute
yourself
so justin let's just wait for one minute
for people to type their questions
otherwise you can start
[Music]
uh
okay i don't see anything in the chat
right now so justin you can't take it
away
sounds good thanks for the introduction
i'll be talking about time traveling
simulators using blockchains and their
applications
this is a joint work with the goyal and
critique sony
blockchains are an emerging new
technology with a variety of useful
properties
so far its primary application has been
to enable decentralized currencies like
bitcoin and ethereum
uh just between these two
blockchain is trusted with securing a
market cap about a trillion dollars
historically blockchains have often been
viewed as a goal of cryptography
and there's been a lot of work on
building blockchains
using cryptography
recently they've also been viewed as an
enabler for cryptography
some recent works have shown that the
properties of blockchain allow it to
work as an alternative to a trusted
setup to enable fairness and multi-party
computation and more
in this work we try to capture new
security properties beyond the standard
definitions which allow a wider range of
results while still being meaningful
in order to define our security notions
we need to quantify the knowledge that
an adversary learned while interacting
with the crypto system
uh
intuitively whatever the adversary
learns in a real action interaction
should be something they could learn on
their own
so let's say that alice knows
a secret and some protocol
and we want to argue that the adversary
does not learn anything about that
secret at the end of the protocol
how we would formalize this
is we would construct a simulator which
can simulate the adversary's interaction
with alice without having access to
alice's secret
uh as a concrete example let's think
about a zero knowledge proof which we'll
use as a running example through the
rest of the presentation
in the zero-knowledge proof the secret
would be a witness to some np statement
then since the simulator does not
require the witness
the adversary can run it locally to
learn whatever it would have learned in
a real execution
and by definition
its interactions with the simulator
can't reveal the witness
the simulation paradigm is extremely
influential
and is commonly considered the gold
standard of cryptographic security for
interactive protocols since it's quite
easy to define the exact behavior that
you require
uh
philosophically
the simulator paradigm captures the
floss uh
captures the idea that whatever a
verifier learns from the proof
it could have learned on its own with
just a bit of extra computation
various relaxations of the standard
definition modify this philosophy by
allowing the simulator extra power
the resulting philosophy allows the
verifier to learn whatever it would have
anybody learned
using that extra power
in this work we propose a new philosophy
anything the simula at the adversary
learns now it could have learned after
waiting until tomorrow
we capture this idea by giving the
simulator the ability to look into the
future
crucially block chains provide the
notion of time which allows us to
exactly define this capability
our primary contribution is our
definition of time traveling simulation
which i'll discuss in a minute
we also highlight the usefulness of our
new notion by giving three round
protocols for zero knowledge computa our
zero knowledge arguments and secure
two-party computation
it's worth noting that three-round
zero-knowledge arguments with standard
simulation are either impossible or so
far require novel assumptions
uh and in the case of two-party
computation no three-round construction
is known with standard simulation
that does not limit the power of one of
the parties
now let's discuss a little bit about
exactly what time traveling simulation
is more exactly
to define the future blockchains give a
natural notion of time since the blocks
are continually added
additionally it provides a predicate to
check if a sequence of blocks is a valid
extension of the current state in other
words it's possible to check if a new
state is actually from the future
and when parties begin the protocol
they're given the current state of the
blockchain
as mentioned earlier to quantify the
security
that this gives
we need to define a simulator which is
not given the witness
and as a time traveling simulator
it instead receives an extension of the
current state of the blockchain by f
blocks
this access to a future state is the
core difference from the standard
simulator definition
you can also define time traveling
simulators for other protocols such as
secure two-party computation
similar in a similar manner
it's very important that states too far
into the future are hard for adversaries
which control and only
only a minority of computational power
um without waiting for that future to
arrive naturally
in order to compute uh that future
quickly
they would have to mind blocks much
faster than the honest parties uh and
that would violate the security of
blockchain
now that we've defined
time traveling simulation we need to
answer how meaningful this new security
notion is
since we do give the simulator
additional power as compared to a
standard simulator
time traveling zero knowledge is
technically weaker than standard narrow
knowledge
however the exact differences depend on
the statement being proven
the weakness of time traveling zero
knowledge appears when the statement
being proven is inherently time
sensitive
for example
when proving knowledge of a solution to
a time locked puzzle
that puzzle will be solved by tomorrow
so a time traveling zero knowledge proof
could leak the simulator the solution
today
however many statements that we care
about are not actually in
uh time sensitive for example a
committed message will never be revealed
until the committer decommits to it no
matter how much time passes in between
for these kinds of statements time
traveling zero knowledge is just as
powerful as standard zero knowledge
for more details including a more
detailed comparison of time traveling
simulation to other relaxed security
notions
please see the whole versions of our
talk or our paper thanks for listening
okay
thanks justin um
okay so we have a couple more minutes so
if any of you have more questions to
justin you can ask now
i'll be monitoring the chat and the q a
just in case
okay
um
[Music]
i guess there are no more questions so
um
thanks justin and i guess we'll go to
the second talk right now
[Music]
so now it's secret sharing slice
formulas
and real circ monotone real circuits
with or dead
thank you very much
okay
so uh
thanks hi everyone
and as mentioned this is the talk about
the secret sharing slice formulas in
monotonous circuits a joint work with
benny applebaum
amazon nathi peter and tony pitassi
and
in this work we studied three models
the first being a secret sharing schemes
which is an information theoretic
cryptographic model
and the other two
are formulas or circuits that are
enriched with special kinds of gates
so there will be other formulas over
slice gates or circuits over monotone
real gates
we will define the define everything uh
shortly
and uh will be interesting in the
connections between these three models
and we'll be able to
gain benefits from all of them
where our goal will be new lower bounds
for uh secret sharing
in the past uh couple of years there
have been major breakthroughs in secret
sharing
and we would like to know if
how much can this these breakthroughs um
improve upper bound in secret sharing
without introducing new ideas
and
we show
that uh there is a transformation from
these uh secret sharing schemes
these new types to formulas over slice
gates and from formulas or slice gates
two
circuits over real gates
and therefore we can take lower bounds
that are already
known for monotone real circuits and
lift them to our model
and
in the other direction we can show that
the these upper bounds also apply to the
circuit and formula models
and
[Music]
now we'll start by defining the three
models and see why it's all interesting
so in a secret sharing scheme
we're given a list of authorized and
unauthorized coalitions from set of end
parties
and a dealer wishes to distribute a
single bit secrets to all the parties
in a way such that it sends one message
to each party
and we wish that every authorized
coalitions from the list will be able to
recover the secret from the shares it
received and that any unauthorized
coalition will learn nothing information
theoretically
on the secret
and our goal will be to realize
such an access structure a list of
authorized and unauthorized coalitions
with minimal total share size that will
be our measure of complexity for this
model
and it's a major open problem in
information theoretic cryptography
what is the best achievable share size
for the worst case
function or access structure
and
the first ones to consider this problem
for general functions were italian in 87
and they showed the really high upper
bound of two to the n which is um
it seems for uh it seemed for thirty
years that um maybe this is the by leo
vaquita and win
2018
they show that this can actually be
improved
and
since then the line of work improved
this uh
total share size for the worst case
function to 2 to the
0.585 n
the thing is that the lower bound for
secret sharing is still really far below
it's not even quadratic
so a natural question to ask is
how much further
can these these recent techniques uh
improve sequent sharing schemes can we
get to
sub exponential complexity or even
polynomial complexity
and we answer this question and the
answer is no
and we show that there exists a function
in motor and p
such that
these recent techniques can only get us
to 2 to the n over log squared and
not below that
so that's the state of affair for secret
sharing schemes
and now we'll define the second model of
formula over slice gate so it's
basically basically a formula where each
gate can compute a slice function
so a slice function
is a function that can take arbitrary
values
for inputs of a specific hamming weight
let's say of hamming weight k
but it must take the value 0 for lighter
inputs and the value 1 for heavier
inputs
so formally it is
a kl slice has l input bits it's
unconstrained
for inputs of size of hamming with k one
above and zero below
and the formula over slices is the
formula which gate computes some kl size
function but
the weight can the fan in l can vary
between these different gates
and
it they are allowed to be arbitrary
large so this seems like a very strong
model
nothing well in
it was shown
in the work by uh lv the first
improvement to the secret sharing
schemes that their work was actually
based on formulas over slices
but if you didn't know that then the
best possible upper down would be in two
to the end since slices can also
implement endor or gates
so we know that's the basic
result
we know nothing about lower bounds prior
to our work
and we'd expect this mod to be very
strong since there are
a lot of different
such slice gates that can can be
incorporated to a circuit
so this number two to the n o choose uh
n over two is just the
number of sliced gates
we think
n input bits and
slice parameter n over two
so this is it for formulas over slices
and now the third model which is the
formulas or circuits with a different
kind of different kinds of special gates
will have monotone real gates
and these gates are completely different
they
only have two input bits
but they can manipulate real numbers
so each set such gate can take as input
two real numbers and it outputs a real
number
but it is limited by a monotonicity we
will only work with monotone gates
where if we increase the inputs the two
inputs of the gate
then it its output also must be
increased
so
if everything is real then how does it
have anything to do with uh boolean
circuits then we say that if a circuit
has only binary
inputs and outputs
then such a circuit will compute a
boolean function but it but it is
allowed to have
real numbers that go through
intermediate wires
this model was originated by put like in
iv7
by thinking of proof complexity
and since
this is an old model
nothing was known for upper bounds but
there were lower bounds
so we know that uh monotone wheel
circuit there is a function which
requires
a circuit of size 2 to the omega and to
the third and a formula of 2 to the
omega
and over log squared m
so
we would like to use this
this lower bound for monotone real
formulas
and take it all the way up to the secret
sharing schemes
but
that was a
one of the hardest parts of our work
i'll talk about it shortly
the first the easy part was the upper
bounds
so
we realized
that in the secret sharing schemes the
modern one which i talked about
with the best share size of three halves
to the end in every such schemes there
was the it was based on
formulas over slices
actually implicitly
these secret churn schemes started with
constructing the formula over slices for
any function and then continued by
implementing it for secret sharing
so it was implicit though not that
obvious for all of the works we needed
to
work a bit hard to
formalize it
and the other part of the upper bound
chain is a
result by rosenbloom
which says that every slice function has
a monotone real circuit for it of linear
size so if we get a formula over slices
we can
simply replace every slice gate with
a small number of monotone reel gates
and
get
this upper bound result
so if you have these transformations
we can go
in the other direction and take a lower
bound for mountain reel circuits
all the way back to sql chain schemes
but this lower bound is not the
the one we wanted to achieve this is
only two to the omega and to the third
because it's for monotone real circuits
and the
the major part of our work was
understanding that we can actually take
the low ground for formulas
and
take it back to the
secret sharing schemes
because
that transformation by the by
rosenblooms that take slice functions
and replaces them with monotone
with circuits it actually creates
motorway circuits with a specific
structure
and
since they have this structure these
circuits are limited and the lower bound
for formulas also applies to them
so
that's in summary the result i'll go
back to the previous slide so we got a
new upper bounds for formulas over
slices and monotone wheel circuits
a new lower bounds
for formulas over slices
and secret sharing schemes for recent
techniques
that are were all based on formulas over
slices
and
to sum things up
uh i think we've seen
really interesting connections between
secret sharing and other monotone
complexity models
and the the natural questions uh to
follow up from here or um
can we find better upper bounds or lower
bounds for actually
all of these models since in all of them
their results are not tight and
everything in between is possible
okay great
thanks for that um if anyone has
questions um i'm monitoring so far
no questions in the chat but
um maybe let's wait for a minute
[Music]
okay great thanks a lot of that
thanks
johannes to
start sharing
[Music]
and we'll move to small hazard free
transducers
oh can you see my slides
yeah
yeah maybe you can get started as well
johannes and then we can do all the
questions in the end
okay i'm fine with that
uh yeah thankfully uh for the
introduction
uh i will present small hazard free
transducers which is joint work with
christophe lansin and moti motif moti
medina which should
also be here i appreciate that
what we look at is the
circuit complexity
but not in binary logic but internally
logic
and
this means that we take the binary logic
and we take a value of zero and one and
we extend it by a third logical value
in our case we call it u because we see
it as uncertainty
in the sense that if you are not sure if
your input is 0 or 1 or anything then
you replace it by
u
[Music]
this is this has been introduced by
clini and
it's been called a 3 valued logic before
we call it the ternary logic
the
extension to basic gates is
fairly natural so if you take a not gate
and you get a certain input zero one
then your output is also certain and if
your input is uncertain then you
don't know it can be zero it can be one
so you also output an uncertain output
um it gets a little bit more complicated
if we look at and gates or r gates
because if you have a input that already
determines the output
you can
output a certain output
so for example if
one of the inputs to your and gate is
zero
then you will always output a zero
[Music]
but in the other case if your output is
one if your input is one
and the other input is u
then you may be a zero it might be one
you never know and you never know what
your and gate will evaluate to so you
also output a u
and this list leads me basically to the
question um
what is the most precise output that we
can have how can we define what we
actually want to compute with
hazard-free circuits
and i get into some technical
definitions or at least that try to
convey the idea of what's behind it
so first we have
function res which is for resolution
it takes a string in the ternary world
and
produces a set of binary strings
that represent
this ternary string so it might be all
resolutions of the ternary string
in the binary world
and then we have the other direction
which we denote by the star operator
which is basically a superposition of
binary strings
it takes a set of binary strings
and produces
the
most precise ternary string representing
all of these inputs
so to say this this is the
string with the
longest common subsequence so to say
and
basically what what these two enable
me or us to do is to define the hazard
free extension of a function
so assume you are given a function in a
boolean world
and
it's called f then we denote its hazard
free extension by fu
and
it's defined in the volume way
we take the set of all possible
resolutions of your input
and we evaluate f on this set which
gives us a set of
possible outputs
and then we take the superposition of
all possible outputs so
[Music]
the has the free extension of a function
basically represents the most precise
output any circuit can have
in phase of uncertain inputs
yeah basically that's also the
definition for hazardous circuits any
circuit c that implements a function
has a hazard
if it does not implement dd as a free
extension
two results that are known on hazard
free circuits
or on the complexity of sfp circuits
well first of all
every boolean function has a hazard free
circuit computing
this has been known for quite some time
but recently um
it's been shown that
there is an exponential separation
between
the complexity of uh
boolean circuits and has a free
counterparts
so
actually
we can find functions f
where the smallest circuit that
implements f
is exponentially smaller than the
smallest circuit implementing the hazard
free
[Music]
function so
and these two works lead us to the
question
that we try to answer in this work
basically
are there functions that have efficient
hazard free implementations
and we answer with here we can construct
efficient circuits
for transducer functions
[Music]
transducer is basically a mini
machine which is defined as this tuple
with a
set of states
so as is the set of states
we have a starting state we have an
input alphabet and an output value
transition and output functions
so the transducer or the transcription
function of the transducer now is
defined by
tau which is the function that
[Music]
a takes of
inputs and produces a string of outputs
of the same link
and what we show in our work is how to
construct
circuits
that
implement the hazard free
transcription function
so and these circuits will have size
linear and size of the inputs
and
a logarithmic in the
size of the inputs
but you see here
that actually we might have
large constants so to say as is the
size of the state space and l is the
[Music]
size of the input alphabet
but
we've seen before that there's this
exponential separation between
[Music]
hazard free circuits and their their
boolean counterpart
so
this basically shows that we cannot get
around these large constants
and
that's it for now
[Music]
quick question honestly but is the lower
bound from ikemaya overall as well for
for transducers as well
like that separation or
no it applies in general
[Music]
i'm not sure if we can directly apply to
the transducers or not
so yeah i would have to look into that
okay okay yeah sounds good um but in
general we cannot
get around
right
sounds good there is one question from
woody um can you say something about the
separation result is it a simple
function
um
is the smaller possibly hazardous
polynomial
sorry i didn't get the last one
oh sorry yeah so there's a question in
the q a
can you say something about the
separation result
uh i guess it's asking about the
separation between uh from ike and maya
at all is it a simple function that they
use
for
the separation
i think it's for um
for matrix multiplication they can show
it
and
i have to lie but if i recall correctly
they reduce the monotone circuits
and
and applied the lower bounds from
monitoring circuits and hazard three
sentence
okay cool
[Music]
yeah
uh
that's it from my side
all right okay great so sorry i
appreciate more questions
nobody is thanking you for the question
and uh
okay yeah do you mind going to the
conclusion page
um
there's another
[Music]
no this is the answer from oh this is
there is an answer here okay there's
another answer by christoph here so i'll
just read for everybody else that the
lower bound applies in the sense that
one could set up a state machine that
just reads and stores the entire input
in its stage
and then computes an arbitrary function
oh okay so so there is a
[Music]
a lower bound here as well in your
theorem
is that correct if i understood crystal
yeah i think what christopher wants to
say is we we can also find a state
machine for for every function which
basically
reads your complete input
stores it and then it gives the
recording output
this will produce a very large state
space and
state space here
appears exponential
all right i see so you still you also
capture kind of the functions that could
be lower bounded right so therefore like
uh this is in a sense kind of
incorporates the lower bound okay
yeah this is the
short answer to your question right i
guess
oh thanks
any more questions
okay there's no more questions thanks
again johannes
and now
[Music]
now william will um tell us about what
does dynamic optimality mean in external
memory
all right thanks so
um okay yeah so i'm bill cusmall this is
joint work with michael bender and
martin farage colton
and
in order to try to make sure there's
room for questions i'm just going to try
to give a very brief overview of our
paper what does dynamic optimality mean
in external memory
so first of all um
what does dynamic optimality mean in
internal memory right so it's this very
old problem the question is
can you come up with some rotation based
binary search tree that is in some sense
the single best search tree in the world
and in particular you would say that a
tree is dynamically optimal
if it's constant competitive with every
other rotation-based binary search tree
on every
input this is kind of the strongest
sense of optimality you could hope for
and this idea was introduced in the
1980s and what makes it so interesting
is we actually
think there is such a tree
so slater and tarzan introduced display
tree which is widely believed to be
dynamically optimal
and although we don't know whether the
split tree is dynamically optimal
we do have a whole bunch of interesting
results in this area so for example
demand at all showed that the tango tree
is within a log log n factor of
dynamically optimal
that's classical dynamic optimality and
there's a whole bunch of other
interesting results there
but what i want to talk about today
is a direction that
researchers have started to consider in
the last 10 or 15 years which is
if that's dynamic optimality in internal
memory
what should it mean in external memory
in the external memory model
so here of course the classic data
structure that you use for your search
tree is the b tree
introduced in 1970s
um
but the focus that we're going to be
really taking today is on an interesting
feature of the external memory model
which is that even though the b tree is
a classic data structure it's actually
not the only tree in town
and let me tell you what i mean
so it turns out one of the peculiarities
of the external memory model is that
there's actually two parameter regimes
for search trees
so maybe the regime we're most used to
thinking about is the query heavy regime
most of the operations being performed
on your tree are queries
and in this tree in this regime b trees
are optimal
and in fact there's been a whole bunch
of interesting work on what should
dynamic optimality mean for b trees this
turns out to actually be itself a pretty
subtle question because you have to
figure out what's the class of data
structures you want to achieve
optimality against
on the other hand
what's interesting about external memory
is that there's also this other regime
the modification heavy workload regime
so this is the regime where you have
lots of insertions updates and deletions
occurring on your tree
and here b trees actually aren't optimal
in fact you can actually implement your
insertions updates and deletions to be
sub constant amortized time
and so that's the the setting that we're
interested in this paper is we wanted to
ask the question what should dynamic
optimality mean
in
this setting in the modification heavy
setting
so i'm just going to briefly summarize
kind of the big picture of what we do in
this paper and i'll be a little bit
informal but i'm happy to
you know talk about any of these in more
detail if anyone's interested
so the first contribution of this paper
is really a modeling contribution how
should we define dynamic optimality in
this setting
and so the first thing we do is we
oh sorry
the first thing we do is we define the
notion of a buffer propagation tree it's
a class of data structures
that
includes kind of the classical data
structures for the modification heavy
setting
but it also captures the various ways in
which you could adapt your data
structure to the specific properties of
a workload for example
taking advantage of the fact that you
know there's going to be lots of
insertions to one part of a tree but
maybe lots of queries to another part of
the tree
so we defined the class of buffer
propagated trees buffer propagation
trees
and we formalized the question of
can you achieve dynamic optimality
against them
our second contribution is we introduce
a new data structure
that we call the jello tree
and the gelatry isn't dynamically
optimal
but it does have an interesting feature
that it's statically optimal in this
model
so the gelatry is constantly competitive
with any buffer propagation tree
with the restriction that that buffer
propagation tree has to pick its
structure up front and it can't change
its structure afterwards
of course this raises the question of
well
can we argue that somehow the gelatry
maybe isn't fully dynamically optimal
but has some sort of weak weak notion of
dynamic optimality
and this brings me to the final
contribution in the paper
which is we show that the jello tree is
constant competitive
with any buffer propagation tree that is
what we call speed limited
so this means that
the opponent the adversary but for
propagation tree
doesn't have to be static but instead it
has this restriction which is that it's
only allowed to spend some limited
fraction of its ios
on restructuring
on changing the shape of the tree
and so we show that if a buffer
propagation if we're if we're talking
about sufficiently speed limited but for
propagation trees
then our gelatry is as good as that
and this is interesting because it kind
of gives a continuum between static and
dynamic optimality
so we're not optimal on any input
sequence but we would be optimal on any
input sequence
that has the property that the optimal
tree for that input sequence only
changes slowly over time
and this is a notion of this kind of
continuum between static and dynamic
optimality you could actually also
define it in internal memory and that's
one of the big questions that
kind of you were left wondering at the
end of this paper is
maybe there's maybe there's something
interesting you could say about for
example splay trees in this speed
limited setting and we don't know the
answer to that question
okay so that's a brief overview of the
results in this paper just a kind of an
informal statement of each of them
um
and one other open problem i just want
to leave you with is that
our the geometry data structure and its
analysis is actually pretty involved
it's a pretty
complicated analysis so another open
problem that i think is interesting is
just can you come up with a simpler way
to achieve these kinds of results in
this model
or do you really need the full muscle of
the jello tree
okay that's my summary of the results
and i'd be
you know very happy to answer any
questions
okay great
thanks william
um okay if anyone has a question you can
chat tab type or um
or raise your hand and i can also
figure out if i cannot mute you
apparently i can
okay so there's one question here from
eric uh sorry what was the speed limit
constraint for internal memory a
sublinear mod number of modifications
good let's see
that's great so
yeah so here's what i'm kind of
imagining
for internal memory so first of all in
external memory it's kind of the same
situation where we're requiring it to
make modifications at almost an unfairly
slow rate
so imagine you say okay you have a you
have a display tree is allowed to do
what display tree does it's not limited
but opt which is your
adversary is restrict constrained so
that it can only for example
do
epsilon rotations
per
[Music]
tree
you know an average of
you know some number of rotations per
either it's epsilon log n rotations per
tree insertion or maybe even just
epsilon rotations per
tree insertion
sorry not transition per query in the
tree
and then the natural question is if you
assume that epsilon is small enough
can you say something
about
being within a constant factor of
dynamic optimality
i don't know does that make sense
okay let's see what eric says
[Music]
eric i think you're allowed to talk if
you would like
yeah that sounds good so you you're
imagining epsilon is a constant in
particular or maybe even less than one
yeah even
even
um
sub-constant possibly yeah like
asymptotically so interesting
yeah it's a cool question
okay do we have any more questions
okay if not let's thank uh william again
i'll thank for everybody
and uh okay so now we'll have
samia brata
talking to us about support recovery in
universal one bit compressed sensing
uh hello everyone uh can you see my
slides
uh yes
yes um he is everyone so my name is
um
what can i do for you sorry
it's all good
um
sorry for some reason siri has been
speaking on my behalf
it's okay okay and i don't know how to
put it off
okay i think i stopped
so
so hey everyone my name is shoma
bhuttopal i'm a postdoc at
google research
and today i'll be talking about support
recovery in universal one bit compressed
sensing which is a joint work with my
phd advisor arya mazumdar
so in the present world the data is
ubiquitous it is everywhere and it's
important to store and reconstruct it
efficiently
and it is a significant challenge to
store the large amounts of data without
some kind of structural assumptions
and the most natural structural
assumption
which
in practice is true
luckily for us is that most signals such
as audio and images are sparse in some
domain so if you do a fourier transform
of images it has it can be represented
as a sparse vector
which means it has only a few non-zero
entries
so
let me give an example that although
most
images which are
uh i mean
which are arbitrarily created look
random and hard to compress for example
these images
uh most images that we care about
are highly structured
and
since they are structured we it can be
transformed by
via some fourier transform or wavelet
transform to
so that it can be represented as a
vector with only a few non-zero entries
okay so we will let's assume that this
change of basis has been pre-applied to
make the data sparse
so let's be a bit more mathematically
rigorous so the signals or the that we
care about can be represented as a
vector
in say n dimensions
and the important thing is that we know
that this vector
vector is parts the signal is passed
that is it has at most k non-zero
entries
okay
and we will call the set of nonzero
indices of x
or the vector to be the support of x
now
interestingly it can be shown that such
sparse signals can be compressed and
reconstructed by using
quantized linear measurements where the
number of measurements is much smaller
than the
the
latent dimensionality which is n
and we can do this by using the
structure that is the sparsity crucially
so let us look at an extreme
quantization setting which is known as
the one bit compressed sensing thing
setting and in this setting what we do
is we compress us and compress a signal
by using the science of
the inner products of with the signal
okay so let me give up just a few more
details to introduce the problem
so suppose sine
is a function which takes
a real number as input and returns 1 if
the input is positive 0 if the input is
0 and minus 1 if the input is negative
and we can extend this notation to
a vector which means that sine of a
vector is the sign of each entry of the
vector
okay
so now
uh
what we do what we have is the following
we have a measurement matrix let's call
it a which has some number of rows
where the number of rows is much smaller
than the number of dimensions that is we
make a must
we make some measurements but the number
of measurements is much smaller than the
dimensionality n
now
what we get to observe is the sign
of this measurement vector measurement
matrix times the
signal vector okay and our goal is to
reconstruct the signal vector from this
observed
and from this observations
so in the reconstruction problem what we
have is the following we have a known
measurement matrix a
we have an unknown signal vector x which
is of dimension n and we have an
observed vector y
where every entry
is plus one minus one or zero since y is
just a sine of a
and there are no signal x
okay and our goal is to recover this
unknown signal x from this observed
vector y
now this problem has applications in
many domains just photography holography
and facial recognition
and an important property that we care
about is the following the measurement
matrix that we choose must work for all
n-dimensional signals which is case
parts that is only have a
few non-zero entries and it is important
in photography because we want a single
algorithm to work for all images that we
take through the camera
and our objectives can be twofold first
of all we can go after signal
reconstruction where we want to
reconstruct the entire unknown signal x
or we can
the other goal is to recover the support
that is we only want to recover the
indices or of the non-zero entries of
the unknown signal
and there are
several possible notions of support
recovery
we can recover the exact support from
the observations
which is also called the universal exact
support recovery now again let me
reiterate that the the
measurement matrix a that we design must
work for all
high dimensional signals with sparsity
at most k
so suppose now that we are okay with
making a few mistakes we do not need to
return the exact support
so we can define two other notions of
support recovery in that context
so suppose we can
make
we can return a set which has a small
number of false positives and a small
number of false negatives that is
suppose it is okay if we make
if we insert a small number of indices
which are not within the support in our
final answer
or we omit a few correct indices of the
support in the final answer
so this is what we call an epsilon
universal approximate support recovery
and this epsilon
denotes the number of mistakes that
we're allowed to make
the other notion is universal superset
support recovery and here we are only
allowed to make false positives that is
we want to return a set
which is a superset of the support of
the unknown signal
we are not allowed to omit any index
from the support of the
unknown signal vector
okay
and let me briefly discuss our results
so for exact support recovery acharya
already showed that o of k square log n
measurements are sufficient to design a
universal measurement matrix
that can recover the support of all k
sparse signal vectors exactly okay
so
for basically for exact support recovery
o of k square log n measurements are
sufficient and this bound is nearly
tight
and
it for for binary signals when it is
known that the unknown signal vector is
binary
the
k square term can be improved to k to
the power 3 over 2.
so for approximate support recovery here
if you look at this result just treat
epsilon as a constant
we can show that o of k log n
measurements are sufficient for
approximately recovering the support of
any unknown signal vector so here we can
improve the index from
of ah sorry here we can improve the
dependency on k from k square to k when
we go from exact support recovery to
approximate support recovery
and we can again show that this bound is
also tight
next if we move on to superset recovery
it turns out that o of k to the power 3
over 2 log n measurements are sufficient
so this is an interesting open problem
can we close the gap between the
sufficient number of measurements
for superset recovery the current upper
bound
on the number of measurements is k to
the power 3 over 2 and the current lower
bound on the number of measurements is o
of k so there is a k to the power half
gap between the upper and lower bound
and be very interesting if it is
possible to close it in some future work
so we can provide other results as well
if
we have more structural assumptions on
the unknown signal vector and you can
refer to it in our paper
so before
uh ending let me just give a brief
parallel with another problem called
group testing so many of you i think are
already aware of this problem here
instead of this problem is very similar
with the one bit compressed sensing
setting but
here the unknown signal is binary the
measurement matrix is also binary and
the operation between the measurement
matrix and unknown signal vector
is not linear but it's a
logical or operation
okay so because of this operation what
we do observe is a binary vector
okay which is
y belonging having
m entries and our goal is again the same
to recover the support of the unknown
signal
now
although this problem has many parallels
with one bit compressed sensing
the in
the crucial thing in group testing is
that an observation of zero
means that all the indices of signal
in the support of that measurement is
zero
and this property can be crucially used
to provide
uh
results for all these notions of support
recovery that are tight
okay but for our problem this results
could not be this techniques could not
be extended which and requires several
new ideas
and this is where i think i will
end
okay thanks very much
um
all right
as anybody else have questions
okay um
in this case let me just see if there's
something in the q a nope
okay so in that case um i'll thank the
speaker again and
all right now thank all the speakers in
the session so thanks for the great
talks
and
yeah we're all
ready to go okay
bye